the Democratic memo has been released
that's huge news if you know what the
hell I'm talking about and I don't want
to assume that everybody does so I'm
gonna give you the backstory now I don't
know how far back I should go in the
backstory I mean I was born in 1984 in
Buenos Aires Argentina skipping ahead a
few years I eventually started hosting
this show and I'll skip all the way up
to a few weeks ago to catch you up where
Republican congressman Devin Nunez
claimed to have a blockbuster memo that
would completely discredit Robert
Muller's Trump Russia investigation
ultimately that memo was released and it
ended up being really not a huge deal
but if the allegations made by Devin
Nunez were true we would have supposed
abuses of the FISA warrant process and
that includes four FISA warrants for
surveillance on people like Carter page
them a new Ness alleging those were
obtained incorrectly and on the basis of
what he claimed was the discredited
Christopher Steele dossier now before we
get into the Democratic memo on the
basis of the new Ness memo alone we knew
that he lied because we know that the
steel dossier has not been discredited
but rather has been partially
corroborated but okay this was what
Devin unit said we know that Devin Nunez
never saw the actual intelligence
documents that his memo was supposedly
written about but okay some of his
colleagues a colleague supposedly did so
we were led to assume that I guess Devin
Nunez knew what was in those
intelligence documents even though we
don't know that then we learned that
there is a democratic memo and we wonder
will it be released or won't it be
released there is a back-and-forth for
several days or a week and ultimately we
learned that it would not be released
either because Trump didn't want to
release it or because it contained too
much unredacted classified information
but for whatever reason we learned it
would not be released until this weekend
the Democratic memo response to the
Devin Nunez memo has now been released
and it directly refutes every single
aspect of the new Ness memo now to be
clear
the Democratic memo refutes the Doudna
the new Nest memo but that doesn't tell
us whether either memo tells the truth
the memos disagree and I'm going to talk
more about that later because that's an
important part of this but let's start
with what the Democratic memo says here
are the major highlights number one the
Democratic memo denies that the steel
dossier was the basis for the Carter
Page investigation in fact according to
Democrats the Carter page investigation
started before the FBI received the
steel dossier and if you believe time to
sort of move forward as we have a
conventional understanding of it it
would then be impossible for the steel
dossier to be the basis for the
investigation into Carter page and in
excuse me in fact the Democratic memo
points out that Carter page has a long
history with Russia that warranted
investigation and that he had been
investigated before and previously it
alleges that Carter page also lied in
testimony to the two lawmakers about
meetings that he had with Russians so
big picture number one the Democratic
memo says we had many reasons to be
investigating Carter page that had
nothing to do with the steel dossier and
we started that investigation before the
FBI started that investigation before
they even had the steel dossier the
Demme memo also argues that the
processes that were used to get those
FISA warrants were totally on the up and
up both in terms of who approved them
and the information that they contained
the DEM memo denies that Christopher
Steele was paid by the Department of
Justice for the dossier which is another
right wing talking point that the memo
allegedly debunks based on the
assertions that it makes and it actually
mentions that there is independent
corroboration of elements of the steel
dossier
I believe this hurts Republicans even
more than if neither of these memos had
been released and I encourage you to
read it for yourself it's only ten pages
but the main points are it says the
opposite of what the new Ness memo said
remember that Nunez himself never saw
the intelligence he was supposedly
describing in
memo but more importantly we now have
the first official statement to the
extent that a letter from Democratic
congressman is an official statement
that says information in the steel
dossier has been corroborated outside of
that dossier now let me get to the part
of which memo do we believe I've just
told you what the dem memo alleges let's
all be skeptical news consumers if you
believe neither memo or you at least
questioned both because you recognize
that both the Nunez memo and the
Democratic memo are both politically
motivated memos good for you
number one but then what do we go to if
we can't ascertain the veracity of the
memos since the underlying intelligence
is classified or not available to us
what can we do I would presume that
unless we have actual evidence that the
FBI acted inappropriately I would
presume we still believe the FBI acted
appropriately right because what we have
essentially are two political memos one
saying the FBI acted inappropriately
without actually supplying us with the
information that would confirm that and
then we have a counterpoint memo from
Democrats saying the FBI acted
completely appropriate appropriately we
don't actually have evidence that the
FBI acted inappropriately and thus I
think our default still is the FBI is
doing an investigation and they're
acting appropriately and FISA warrants
have to be approved and they're not
unilaterally signing off on these things
themselves now if you don't believe the
Democratic memo but you believe the new
Ness memo I would just ask you why right
why do you believe the new Ness memo
which contained no actual evidence but
just assertions and Devon Nunez didn't
even see the intelligence he claimed to
be citing but then you don't believe the
Democratic memo that doesn't really make
sense to me and further this has even
more intensely backfired for Republicans
because the Steele memo is framed as
being partially corroborated and every
time I mentioned this pass
you get the online trolls and you get
the cottage industry of people who like
to just do attack videos on the David
Pakman show saying Pakman is lying that
Trump urinated on Russian prostitutes I
never said that that piece of the
Russian dossier has been corroborated
but there are many elements that have
been and they relate to Carter page they
relate to Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
etc the question I come away with after
reading the Democratic memo is if only
ten percent of the Democratic memo is
accurate why hasn't Carter Page been
indicted yet and that may well be one of
the next shoes to drop on this thing
send me your thoughts I think it is
fascinating how this memo has backfired
on Republicans they release a memo that
has a very little meet for lack of going
back to the nothing burger motif and
then now if the Democratic memo is
accurate it looks really really bad for
people like Devon Nunez send me your
thoughts you can discuss this and any
other topics from today's show on our
subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
today's program is sponsored in part by
blinking
entire idea behind blinka stand the
service they provide is perfect for me
and I assume really great for a lot of
people in our audience too if you watch
this show you know I read a lot of
nonfiction books and blink astiz an app
that takes nonfiction books and it
distills the most important points and
insights from the book down to a
powerful package of information which
can be read or listened to in about 15
minutes on your mobile device or tablet
you can zip through books really quickly
I still think it's great to absorb the
wisdom of books by reading them slowly
and in their entirety deep reading is
what it's called but not everybody I
know I don't have the time to read all
the nonfiction books that I really want
to so for the ones I can't read blink
astiz the next best thing
huge selection for one low flat rate you
get access to thousand
of books you can switch between text and
audio both online and offline and you
also get personalized recommendations
based on books you've already chosen
join over 4 million people already using
bling cos that made the iTunes best apps
of 2017 list it's free to try but you
can also get a 20% discount on a yearly
membership by visiting blinkers comm /
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
we've put a link in the description
underneath the video again that's blink
accom /p a que ma n